if you're not getting through a scene if
you're not feeling it how do you do that
how do you work through it you fail
you just fail and that's great I
love that that's it's a little awkward
to be talking about because you know I'm
not trying to come across as some kind
of like dude that's impenetrable I've
been humbled many times in my life and
still carry a lot of humility around
with me from those events of when I was
extremely humbled but um no no I I I if
I I believe that if you're not putting
your head out on the chopping block
every time you walk out on stage or
every time they say the cameras rolling
then you're not you're not doing the
best you can you you have to fail I fail
constantly every day when I'm working
and and I do not get nervous about it no
that is epic I wish that I could
have that